Type identification this
is an interview with mr.
David irvine coming in
as david owen who is
a boilermaker on the sydney harbour bridge.
You served your time in the early days
in the first belfast what it. Yes
yes i served my time in belfast
work when clark. It was in the same street
of the same road as town and world. We
call it the week yard work when clark.
They work nine or three quarter hours
a day. And no work no pay. I was apprentice
i don't know what my father gave paid
for my apprenticeship. Well as the moment
i went to serve my time but i am and i am
not
a pure magic home where an ordinary hammer
and two of us were knocking rivers lines
and my dad what he paid as i said before
i don't know but we work nine or three
quarter hours
a day and we did not work. We never got
paid with one piece work. You've got to
take it out on the right on the open and
we're right to post all weathers. And when
i serve my eventually finish my five years
apprenticeship. Of course i'll bet camp
your marriage hammers then there was
a lot of pure magic revelling. And i went
up to get my journeyman's tickets and
they told me that i guess likely pit did
two weeks to pull up. That was through the
wet weather that we rock and when i
lost 100 actually six years of my
apprenticeship. So did you go to technical
school while you were doing your time in
those days. No technical school to teach
you the hardest knock rivers down with
a hammer was just and that his job was still
not his job. But we had very big ships
we build are next door to us. One of the
outstanding things that i can remember was
. Witnessing the launching of the titanic.
You know and was. 911 that was the first
ship i saw launched. I was
a boy about ten years old and. I don't get
my age wayne and i did you actually work
on the titanic. You know that was an old
and world that was in the big shipyard.
But shipyard just beside each other and
one was what we call the we are the big
garden. Do you embody talk about the
titanic when it was launched. I know was
a perfect launching but we all know the
disaster now you can read about the
disaster if you want any doctors up here
you've got the doctors in there are
doctors up here and up the moment you
know these read about the time of the day
time with all the literature they keep in
there when in those days when you worked
on the on the ships in the yard at belfast
was the work hard from start to start
very hard of you didn't. Well said before.
Priscilla i love you didn't work. You
didn't get paid the harder you work the
more you earned. How did that work
where you worked for a number
of rivets you put down
a do they give you so much per hundred. So
much per hundred varied and prices. Well
a pendant where you worked your member
how much was in those days. Yes i was
earning my. Twenty shillings
a week which was exceptionally good no stage
as an apprentice twenty one shillings
. In the war came on they give
us all a twenty once a guinea
a week bonus. Whether you want
to not you just got one guinea
a week extra on your money and the war years
in the first world war and you were to
the shipyards there all through the war.
All through this. Did you build naval
ships there. No never. Ships know all
merchant ships. White star line. Of
titanic mm. There was
a larger ships flood in those days. No
warships built in your you know what ships
at all. Things got flak right about 1923
and. I was never out of work really and
i saw where they were building
a harbour bridge here and i wrote the
doorman longs and they said that i would i
think they probably employ me. Which i
did like about iran about twenty three
twenty four and i got the harbor bridge
and from there i had five years there
a foreman river. And workshops and from
there we went over the comedy wow and work
during all the more than
a million times and has been that meeting
with him cockatoo talk who are where did
you start then and the war years i was there
all during the war 1940 forty two. Is
it yes yes. thirty no forty forty to forty
five. You worked with larry short i
understand i did i work larry work for me.
One of the greatest chaps i ever met my
life was only short he didn't work. Wrong
with me he was. He was an hour and work
credits from me for
a few days. Not long. Not long enough
because i had them forever of me to stay
because he was an outstanding personality
in the shops. He was an arm worker and
eventually became chairman of the committees.
Do you member any of those meetings
and he was union meetings there. Oh yes
meetings there and meetings there very
often with phillips and phillips and don
used to come over there really. Often. And
what used to happen those body laurie was
laurie was already capable of handling
and i can always remember
her. Lori's. Trying
to phillips all the time polluters only
that put in the wedge and either that and
sorry you started. I forgot to put the
wedge at the day. This little this little
wedge was already going in but larry was
a fine chap we used to go to the
domain to listen to him. He had
a lot of friends. You know want to
be a fellow. You know he's done
a lot of good for
a lot of people that people know nothing
about. What about at the at the shipyard.
Do you member him to dob you
emblem challenging thornton as
a first time. Secretary. You
know. Yes well you see a bit of
a go down and that was really their own
work as it was their trouble. But i
remember they treated. Larry very very badly
were very sore about the treatment he
got at the key once he got a bit of
a bashing there are these commas that
whatever they wear i don't know what they
were but he came out top anyway and
he's on the right place. They have
a look back since they got him in there.
Do you remember any of the shock committee
meetings do you did you ever attended he
was shot committee meetings shot meetings
that we had a pretty regular we had
a pretty regular but nothing outstanding
during the war. We're all pretty loyal.
There's
a lot of trouble in belfast where you came
from and what year was it these stairs
only twenty three you came here is
when did you first start serving your
apprenticeship 1914 1914
thirteen was only thirteen them.
Do you remember belfast in those days my
word i do. Yeah three some very hard times
national strikes. National strike the
place was in darkness. And we had the
upheavals there and 1916. Now the dublin
rebellion of course everybody knows about
that. Well it came up in the belfast.
And that as more or less intensified me
coming to this country because they put
a curfew on. And you can realize even
realize at twilight in the
summertime you've got
a twelve hours. You work twelve sleep
and play twelve. And all the boys
when you were on our age we went with
park plenty of park to play and they put
a curfew on it. We had to be indoors at
7:30 every night. And if you weren't
indoors you know walk around we are these
damned soldiers there they were running
around with guns they can only handle
them and if you didn't keep your hands up
when they took you they tutor. So you might
up to what mile after go to the police
station we rode on after
7:30. So there was a hell of
a lot of people like me. They went to
different companies. Did you ever get married
up like that. I guess
a pickup once find twenty one shillings
right want one guinea. Do everything
else when you were
a boy. Never. And never want to do it again
because the back of beyond your them
guns. Is probably soldiers they were no
good. They're all young fellow come out of
the war and i didn't see much. No not much
more they were more there was enough.
Remember when you earlier when you
were a boy. Earlier when you were
a boy at thirty years ago. Eighty four
years ago she was you ever going to school
in belfast what was school like an art
school a very good very good. And
a matter of fact there and that is your
handwriting is very good. It's going to
tell you a story there. I went to
a doctor recently here. And i write
at the different prescriptions that i
have and the medicines that i was taking.
And all these medical need names i have
a right on the paper and i wrote it on the
paper and i took it into the doctor and
i challenge i'm having no regret it. Where
did you learn to write like that. He
said i've never seen writing like that
since my dad left ireland. I said well
that's right. I came from belfast. And when
i said belfast he never looked at me. I
thought he was going to cut my throat because
he come from dublin. So you can read
the link for yourself. Apartment
it. Street. When you were
a boy. Belfast when you were
a boy it must be something.
During the first war you were in
a reserved occupation of the shipyards
weren't you. Yes i was but i. I
committed i don't know what it was an
unpardonable sin or not. I joined up when i
was sixteen under my brother's name. And
i was just ready to go overseas i was in
the royal field artillery as
a driver and i went through all over the
business of the soldier and just read an
expeditionary life. When they woke up
that i was going to the shipyard and they
discharged me and i bet it was
a very funny since of my brother's name
every time i called robert there are mine.
There was no rubber there i find there so
they got you on there when i got me there
you know it and i've had quite a bit
of experience there when you were
a young lad what you what i used to do in
the spare time in belfast in those days.
Oh well we played cricket and my mind you
know forget their work nine or three
quarter hours
a day. Five minutes past 6:00 in the
morning. You started work and i'd walk three
miles for the shipyard three mother and
three melbourne but they didn't i didn't
feel like overnight success
right. But i did i played
a bit of soccer. What i've liked enough
shock or over there that when i came
through here in adelaide i represented
south australia against the japanese i've
struck against the chinese you know you
know breeders about twelve to nothing to it
i was an adelaide. So what do you do did
you work saturdays in those days you were
did you work saturday saturday saturday.
And what all day already on alimony.
Morning morning. Half
a day. Some of their so that was how many
days there were how many hours and we're
goes forty eight was it in those days
bitty six and belfast fifty six fifty six
hours
a week but in adelaide whenever we had it.
I mean we came through your early and we
got off the boat to make sure the wharf
labourers there no toilets were getting
thirty bob
a day. We thought they were telling lies
but they were there are getting. He said
there's a good company
that will do us quite
a few of us there were bullet makers and
pool and steals other shipyard there. But
they had a harbor and
they grabbed us and paid
a passage back from melbourne. Give us
a job there. That was doing twenty three
for their non-predatory yeah there are so
whether depression has started that the
depression hadn't started there. No one
else things were pretty good there. We got
good money over there. Bills still they
were very good. Now but larry
sure i. I don't remember
larry at all in the same one day and his
office. My wife and i were going overseas
. We're going to america. And i knew larry
i just came back at that time. And i
call in for
a little bit of extra. Knowledge of what
happened. And he concluded by telling me
to bring plenty of pennies with me he said
because these new pennies are great for
the kids up with them
he was quite right too.